[Music]
hey everyone welcome to a brand new
tutorial series dedicated to user
interfaces and control nodes within the
GTO engine it's going to be very similar
to the firstperson shooter tutorial
series that's already on my channel and
ongoing so if you're familiar with that
it's a very similar setup we're going to
be doing things step by step we're going
to start very basic and try to move
through all the different aspects of the
control node user interface system like
themes different setups like menus
settings heads up displays we'll try to
touch on as much as possible and just
kind of learn together about how all of
these things work and what you can
actually do with control nodes and user
interfaces within the goto engine today
we're going to be focusing on just a
very basic main menu setup it's going to
be sort of a crash course we're going to
try to touch on little bits of of
everything familiarize ourselves with a
control node system so we have a a solid
foundation to start making some really
cool stuff later on on for this video
and any videos going forward I'm going
to be working from G 4.3 I'm on the dev
6 version of that and we'll probably
update to stable once that's released I
have a completely empty project but you
can work from your own if that's what
you're doing or you can start a new one
that works too and if you'd like to grab
the source files for this video or any
future videos in the series you can grab
those on my patreon all right let's get
started the first thing we need to do is
create a a new scene that's going to be
for our main menu and we're going to be
using a uh not the user interface uh
root node because that's just a control
node we'll get into that in a little bit
we're going to click on this other node
button and let's take a look at the
different control nodes that we have
available to us now typically when
you're organizing your control nodes
your user interfaces you're going to be
using container nodes now each one of
these containers has a specific use case
and in our case we're trying to recreate
this menu that's in the center of our
screen a very basic main menu style to
do that we're going to use this Center
container node now what this does is it
takes anything that's a child and It
Centers it within whatever the size of
this container is so let's use that as
our parent the first thing we need to do
is obviously this is not very big we
need this to stretch across the entirety
of our screen now on the right hand side
you'll notice our control class uh
options over here now these are going to
be available able for every uh control
node that that you use and we're going
to be looking at layout now in layout
there's a lot of different options the
one we're going to be focusing on right
now is this anchors preset what this
anchor does is it it stretches the Box
according to where you want your anchors
to be now you can anchor it to the top
left to the bottom right or top left to
the lower right for example if I wanted
to do just the left side of the screen I
could do left wide and you'll notice
that it's stretched now to the left side
of that viewport we want this to stretch
the entirety of the viewport and we can
use what is called the full wct option
now that has stretched it to the size of
our screen and now if I were to create a
child within this node it's going to
make it right there in the center in
fact let's go ahead and do that so you
can see how that works let's take what
is called a label node which is just a
plain text node add that as a child
and I'm at the center you'll notice that
this is centered again right in the
middle of that screen now we're not
going to use a label note as a child
what we're going to do is grab another
container called a panel container so
this is another container but it uses a
style box What's called the style box to
create a panel now you can't see the
panel yet because we don't have anything
inside so let's go ahead and add our
label
again we zoom in you can see we've got a
a panel now
that's containing our our label node the
next thing we need is another container
type called a vbox container now what
this container does is it arranges its
children vertically it's going to stack
them so one after another now at this
point we can start adding some children
to this vbox container and and fill out
our menu the first thing I want is a
title so I'm going to use a label now a
label node has a text box up here and
the inspector that we can add in some
text we'll type in main
menu next we're going to add some
buttons again these nodes have a very
specific use case and I think part of
the issue is knowing what to use and
when to use it we're just going to use a
very basic button We'll add that as a
child and like the label node you can
add text to that button and for our text
let's call this new game so we have our
button we have our label it doesn't look
very good but we'll get to that in a
second when we talk about some themes
let's fill this out with a few more
buttons we'll make this one a continue
button and if you want to duplicate that
you can click this node right click and
duplicate or press contrl
D then for this one let's add this be a
settings button and then our last one
can be quit all right so we have our
title for our menu we have our four
buttons Let's test this out let's save
our control node we'll call this main
menu and let's test it we'll run it and
there's our menu you'll notice that the
size matches that that viewport box and
we've got our title and all of our
buttons the buttons are actually
operable because the nodes are built
that way we just need to make it look a
little bit better let's click on our
panel container and head over to the
right side in the inspector Tab and and
in our control settings you'll notice we
have this theme option now this this
option is kind of hidden away but this
is where you can control the look of
every aspect of your control node
sometimes people will tell you to look
to this theme overrides and it can be
enticing because it kind of gives you
what you want right away my
recommendation would be to avoid uh
overrides unless absolutely necessary
using theme is going to give you a lot
more control and it's it's going to make
things replicable and you won't have
some item that didn't magically change
because you used an override so I would
avoid overrides and I would go for
themes speaking of themes let's go ahead
and create one you can click that you'll
click new theme and a step that some
people kind of forget is when you create
a resource like that you can save it and
if you save
it you can always reload it now that I
have a theme what the heck do I do with
her right you've probably had this en
countered this screen before and had no
idea what to do with it and I admit it's
it's a little bit um it's a little
unclear this is a preview of a a good
variety of control nodes that uh and how
they look within this theme we don't
want it to look like this and we want to
customize it so let's start with the
panel container we've got my theme is
applied to panel container and we need
to go to this field right here we're
going to add Plus and we're going to add
a new type that this theme is going to
control basically it means that we're
going to make this node have uh new
defaults within this theme now if you
don't add this node it's just going to
pull from the default theme which we
don't want so we'll take the panel
container We'll add that as a a type
you'll notice that it's in this drop
down now you can also go to manage items
and you'll see it here on the left side
of types open this up a little bit or
you can go through any of the control
nodes or presets and simply import
whatever those settings are with the
data this is going to bring a lot of
stuff into your theme so I would kind of
do it piece by piece so we have our
panel container the next part that we
want to look at is this stuff over here
on the right you have different tabs
here and Within These Tabs are the
options the settings that you can adjust
within this node type now a lot of these
are are empty for panel container
except for this style box option and
this style box option is where the panel
is getting its visuals where it's
getting its look so if we want to change
that using our theme we go to the
stylebox tab right now we just have
panel in the future there might be other
options so we're going to click the plus
button that's going to create a override
here well I shouldn't say override it's
not really an override it's a a new
default within this theme and with that
we can add our own style boox flat and
if I do that you'll notice that we've
already changed the look of our panel
now this is another thing that you can
save in fact I would recommend it and
you can have a folder of all these
different UI resources that you can pull
from you don't want to create something
and then lose it because you unloaded
something or or deleted it that would
not be good so let's go ahead and save
this we'll call this um in fact let's
create a new folder so let's set up a
primary and now we can we can make some
edits and this is probably the area that
some of you want to get to but you don't
know how to get to because this is where
we can add some padding and adjust some
of the look real easily so in our
stylebox setting let's go ahead and add
some padding because that looks pretty
rough the padding is in content margins
maybe not the best word choice but
that's where the padding is so let's add
some padding let's do 50 pixels on all
sides and we're already getting some
spacing there you can add a border
width which adds a border to your box
you can add a uh a blend which sort of
gradually goes from the the background
color to the Border color sort of like a
a bevel effect you can add a corner
radius
now we have rounded Corners now the
expand margin option is going to sort of
Bring It Outside of its container box
like that which there's some use cases
for that but for what we're doing we we
don't need that and you can add a
shadow change the color or the alpha of
that shadow or you can offset it to make
it a drop down Shadow and then we have
an anti-aliasing option which generally
would be be turned on so I'm going to
put some settings in here feel free to
you know make your own look um I'm not
going to have a border for our color
we're going to do something that's sort
of a darker darker gray like that and I
don't want rounded corners and Shadow is
that's fine we can keep the Shadow and
content margins that's that's okay for
now so we set up our new panel container
uh theme within our custom theme it's
working great if I added another panel
container and use the theme it would
automatically look like that that's the
whole point of themes right so let's
adjust these buttons next let's uh click
on our main button and we'll go down to
our layout go to our theme let's load up
the theme that we
created and do the same process we're
going to go and add Button as a type now
we've got a whole bunch of new options
because buttons a different type of node
it has different presets different
things that we can change we've got some
colors that we can adjust constants that
we can adjust the font font size an icon
if we added an icon and then we have all
of these stylebox options base type
we'll get to in just a second because
it's a really Nifty tool it's just it's
not explained super great okay so let's
set up a new button style box because I
don't like this default color we're
looking
at normal which is the the normal state
of our button and let's create a new
style box I'm going to put your
attention to this right here this is a
pin button and what this is going to do
is it's going to make any changes that
we do within this normal states and any
style box that set up that we use it's
going to make it apply to all of these
other um States if we make style boxes
for them so we want to pin this because
uh we're going to use this as the sort
of
default setting for our buttons created
a new style box so let's save that
because we want to keep that right we'll
call this button and we'll call this
primary and let's adjust it so we're
maybe like a medium gray and then we
need to add some content margins because
it is way too tight we need to breathe a
little bit there are a couple things
that I'd like to change real quick and
that's the the overall width
of our menu is a is a little thin so I'd
like to set a default minimum size for
that and then let's get a little bit
more space in between our our buttons so
for the first thing we need to go to the
panel container node and let's go ahead
and close that theme because we don't
need it right now and in our our layout
settings we have this option for custom
minimum size now I want the minimum size
to be a little bit bigger obviously than
zero uh so let's set it to 3 00 maybe a
little bit bigger 400 there we go and
then the other thing that I wanted to
change is the spacing here between these
buttons now remember we use this
vertical box container this is taking
all the children nodes that we set up
and layering them in a vertical fashion
there's an option in these vbox and hbox
containers and it's it's in this
override right here so let's go ahead
and load our theme
and add a new type for our vbox
container there we go and then we have
an option here in our constants and we
want to change the the amount of
separation between our buttons so let's
add that to our theme and then let's
make this bigger maybe
10 maybe 20 that looks pretty good all
right now we've got some more separation
in our buttons all right our label it's
not not looking so hot so let's go to
our label let's Center this like we've
centered the rest of our buttons so in
our our label settings there's a
horizontal and vertical alignment just
like any other text editor we want to
set this to Center and now we've
centered it and let's also make some
theme adjustments so we'll sign our
theme go in here add label and let's
adjust the font size let's make this
bigger
maybe like 30 pixels now let's say you
wanted to adjust the the spacing around
this label now this sort of a a
roundabout way to do this but this is
how you're supposed to do it so in the
the label options there's another style
box setting so we need to add a style
box and it's going to be style box empty
now empty is different from flat or
Texture and that it there's no there's
no background there's no color there's
none of that there's no border it's just
padding okay so we have our style box
empty and we have our content margins so
let's add to the the bottom here and
make it a little bit more spacing there
we go if you've ever done cascading
stylesheets this is feels very similar
we're almost there there's one other
change that I'd like to make and that's
what if I want to have a different color
button for my buttons currently all the
buttons are using the same style and we
don't want that so this is where we're
going to go back to this base type
setting it's kind of a weird way to set
this up but it does make sense as soon
as you you do it a couple of times now
the base type is not available if we're
using the the base type we need to
create our own type okay so if we go
into manage
items and go to edit items you can
actually add your own type so let's say
I wanted to add
a new game button type we'll click that
we'll close that go to our new game
button type and now we can make
adjustments except it doesn't know what
our adjustments are we need to set the
base type now the base type for our new
game button would be a button if we set
that now we have all all the button
options for our new game button type and
we can make those adjustments the second
part to this is you need to assign this
custom type to the actual control node
so if I'm in my uh scene tree over here
I'll click the new game button that I
created and let's go down here to theme
variation now we don't have them preset
we'd have to set our theme and our our
settings to do that but you can type it
in so if I type type in new game button
and select that as my type variation
then any changes that I make with this
is going to show up in my control node
so let's add a new normal let's add a
new stylebox flat and you can see we
have a different button type it is a
little bit of a pain to get the settings
that you were using into the settings
that you want to use I think a
workaround for this is to actually
quickload our button
primary and then resave this as a
different type so we'll do
button
secondary we'll save that and then let's
go back to our button here into our
theme and now we can make adjustments to
our secondary button style box we can
make this say more of an orangey looking
thing kind of like that and that's how
you make different variations of the
same control node all right I know that
was a lot and it wasn't extremely
specific about most of it but I wanted
to touch on just the process of creating
a very very basic user interface and
what goes into that and all the things
that you can change going forward we're
going to be very focused on what we're
working on the first step I believe is
going to be an animation setup and then
we'll move into different user interface
types setting up settings saving and
loading continue screens new games
quitting um and different heads up
displays as much as we can touch on
within user interfaces and and see where
we go so so thanks for watching I'm
really excited to really dive deep into
this user interface stuff and um as
always keep creating all right guys if
this tutorial was helpful consider it a
like And subscribe to the channel as
we're going to be covering a lot more
thanks to all of my patrons who keep
this series going you too can get access
to the project source files by joining
my patreon you can download everything
there and you'll also get early access
to my videos and sneak Peaks at Future
tutorials thanks for watching and as
always keep creating
[Music]